here we go in five four three two one
yes and all the [ __ ] people that make
me feel lazy in this world is - okay
make me feel you in the rock you [ __ ]
don't look like you ever sleep and I
don't know no days off that's why I love
is unattractive ass he's a he's a person
that that motivates me inspires me in
effect that we're we're coworkers were
friends I think is I think it's like
it's a blessing it's a blessing to be
around that yeah because it truly it's
it's uplifting you know it makes you it
just makes you weed out the circle when
you're around people that truly give you
like give you some good serve a good
value to you and your life you then look
at those that don't and you can you can
then push away so I'm big on I'm big on
personality I'm big on energy I'm big on
will and once I believe that is
contagious so if you have a bunch of
laziness and a bunch of [ __ ] around
you naturally it's gonna feed off you're
gonna find yourself becoming what's in
your environment so I feel the exact
same way and when I see I see that in
you I see that in you I've seen avatar I
see you I see you yeah but a guy like
that like I always wonder like how much
of that is look I've had sleep experts
on the podcast to tell you like like
there's real problems if you don't get
enough sleep
like you could you have a much higher
risk of Alzheimer's well there's other
serious issues but I see a guy like the
rock I'm like how the [ __ ] does he sleep
what where's the room to for sleep you
know that that's true I can't say that
I'm that I've witnessed the sleep
patterns but he's a he's a late ass so
he does I know he's sleeping to some
rest which is well-deserved
but you know when you when you say you
had these sleep experts and stuff on
it's always a thing that I go back and
forth about because what is enough sleep
like I'm a person I function high off of
six to seven hours yeah six seven hours
I'm I'm functioning yeah five hours I'm
great
do I do the five hour thing all the time
no but if I have to I'm fine I don't
need the eight and the nine like that's
too much for me like I'm I'm an early
riser and now I'm getting older you know
if I can get in that bed by 9:30 or
10:00 on an off workday I'm very happy
with that but then I'm up at 5:30 I'm up
at 5:00 so what is it enough sleep what
do they tell you this really depends on
the person there are people that have a
gene where they can just sleep for hours
at night I got gone oh my god I got that
what is that gold what is that what does
this means you got special gene goddamn
right Amalia yeah that's um [ __ ] there
are there are people that just don't
need as much they can they can go a long
time without sleep diagnosed me I'm one
of those people you thought you might be
I bet a lot of high functioning people
are cuz your body tends to you get more
efficient you know like you you're
always going you're burning hard so your
body's like when it's time to shut down
it's like shut down get that five six
hours in alright do you do well I will
confess this I am an amazing cat Napper
yeah I'm one of those guys if you stop
talking to me long enough
i'ma fall asleep right here it's
something about silence real and just
not doing anything and I just well it's
probably probably going on momentum all
the time you probably you're probably
going on motivation and momentum okay
then when your body has this break
you've already here's a little sleeper
that's just right I'm dead serious
that's I know for sure that that's
accurate
cuz I'm how catnapping heartbeat do you
feel like you've hit a good balance so
this is what I was wonder about guys
like you or guys like the rock when I
look at your Instagram your social media
and you're just constantly going like
god damn do you ever feel like you do
too much like maybe I just need to take
a little break here do you ever feel
like that I think
perception definitely perceives reality
you know what looks like so much isn't
always so much because you have a
schedule and you know within that
schedule there's the things that mean
the most that come in act is downtime
you know me in my house is downtime even
though it's still active and I gotta be
dead and I'm with the kids and a wife in
this conversation and I'm running around
and I'm back for that still exes
downtime for me like I'm shutting a work
off so the phone is any office I'm not
going back to get it until the morning
and it's all conversation it's all TV
it's all Taco Tuesdays it's couch and
cuddling you know baby time whatever
that's my downtime because I'm taking a
step outside of the other [ __ ] that's
wise that's that's what I think I do
very well I can step outside the other
[ __ ] I can separate it so I think when
you're able to do that then you're
you're managing your mental you don't
mean like if it's if it's always one
thing all the time that's how you
[ __ ] drive yourself crazy cuz you
never you're never shutting it off yeah
and I think I do a good job of shutting
shutting this off and focusing on this
like when I want my family I'm with my
family nothing is nothing interjects or
comes in between that's fantastic that's
so important it's understand that's
beautiful I doubt that's gigantic I
think I figured it out that's it you
mean you've got so much success it's all
you have to be with that [ __ ] phone
all the time that's that that's the
phone is the big one right well phone
the phone is is the gift and the curse
mm-hmm you know I think that we we shout
out the gate and saw the gift oh my god
it's it's it's community is connecting
us we're able to share we're able to
meet new people we're able to stay in
communication with with all people find
new people as entertainer I can engage
with my fans and this is so dope and
then after that you get hit with the the
curse and the curses there's a there's a
high level of negativity that's out
there that's on that [ __ ] you know
there's there's a lot of people that are
you know not happy or going through
things and they interject a certain
amount of negativity and hatred through
these devices these devices are the
easiest way to touch everybody so when
you're just consumed on that [ __ ] all
day you start to see yourself being a
part of the negative [ __ ] yeah so what
I've learned to do is go I don't I don't
need to see that I don't need to see
that [ __ ] I don't I don't pay that any
mind I don't read that [ __ ] for what
it's not it's not helping me it's not
making me better it's not it's not
pushing me to new limits if anything is
taken up just creative space by me
literally spending time going and
navigating through what I think is is a
bunch of [ __ ] you know so I don't
let the device beat me and at one point
I definitely did at one point it was
everything there was everything you know
now I separate it I'm not embrace clear
of it what when you realize what it is
when you see when you see the bad you
know when you see the bad side of it I
thought the other day this is some real
[ __ ] and it really made me think my
phone died my phone died and I'm driving
and I was using the [ __ ] maps and I
said [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am I get to with
I don't know where I'm going I said I
was like you know how did we how did we
get from point A to point B before the
map [ __ ] what were we doing that I used
to print out directions from Google Maps
I remember that but then before that how
did you get to the places where you were
going that you didn't know how to get to
I don't even remember remember Thomas
guys do you remember Thomas Scott I did
have a Thomas guy when I first moved to
LA I did have a Thomas guy and I know
look a hundred percent bill burr had one
two a three years ago
but it really [ __ ] me up because I was
like how do we don't even know how how
to do the common yeah the the the norm
anymore because the device has made
everything available and I literally had
to to drive to store rocket buy a
charger charge up my phone to get back
and use the map to get to where the [ __ ]
I was going I had no idea how to get
there I had no I didn't know no numbers
by heart I didn't know who I was gonna
call oh my god this is the moment where
I was like what level of success have I
reach I just pulled over and I said here
and I was like how the [ __ ] am I gonna
get the widow's bear phone man I don't
know what it were a backup phone it felt
like the end of the world if it felt
like it was over house like [ __ ] and
that crazy I dependent you are but
that's when the light bulb started to
click yeah it started to click like how
how do we function without I want to go
backwards a little bit yeah it's still
there I still need it I still think it's
dope with all of the things that we can
do want it but I still want to be able
to put it down and step away from it my
kids to be able to step away from it
that's why when I come in the house my
phone is up cuz I can't I can't [ __ ]
and get playing it's all about being on
your phone if you see me doing the same
thing right right so that time those
conversations me wanting to know about
your day you talking to me about your
day your friends who you like who don't
you like my daughter you what boy who
what no ok my son yeah I like somebody
who oh jesus here it comes it's a great
thing and I want to be able to have
those moments and you know I think it's
it's it's big to make sure that you
prioritize that are you worried about
what comes next hundred percent I'm
worried that something's gonna be way
more intrusive than that it'sit's what
do you mean it's already happening yeah
the biggest scare happened already with
the the the FaceTime [ __ ] that happened
where whatever whoa Apple on the iPhones
it was like people could listen in to
your oh yeah if you didn't need to pick
up the FaceTime you could just
yeah and you know that was the scariest
[ __ ] ever because it's if it's that easy
to have a bug like that what's the thing
that's not a bug
that's there that you just don't know
about oh there's definitely government
listen to us well hunter is it yeah 100
everything everybody says and then in
case one day you do something wrong they
go by your side mr. Hart
we'd like you to sit down from NYU
something hundred percent yeah so the
fear is the next level of them are
intrusive you know I think everything
has become intrusive now like the
toughest thing for me is that there is
no there is no privacy outside my home
right you know the the amount of money
that you have to now spend just on
security on you know people to to be
with me security to be on my home you
know it's like they're there literally
is no privacy and it's not a bit you
complain about it because without the
fans without the people that support me
I wouldn't be where I am but there's no
middle ground right you know there is no
handshakes anymore it's it's how you
doing right right right yeah a handshake
is so much better right I get a moment
like I'm we can talk if that's what you
no no yo say it now weird cuz you you're
doing this to me it's kind of weird to
have a conversation so you're just
starting to see yourself become a little
older and wiser and uh just really see
the times for what they are and see the
direction that we're going in this
people and just hope and pray that we
find a middle ground because I think
right now that is it one yeah that's
what I'm feeling now no I feel it too
and I especially I mean what you're
talking about is you being super famous
and losing all your privacy but
everyone's losing their privacy
yes slowly but surely it's it's
happening to you because you're very
famous and because you do something
that's in the public eye and people want
to see you and they want to stick that
camera in front of you but there's gonna
come a point in time where what we're
dealing with now which is like you have
to turn your phone on you have to you
know you have to reach out to somebody
you have to put something up that's that
steps gonna be out of the way who's
gonna be people being able to act
that's your life yeah pretty you know
you know the bad here's what I said it's
bad that really [ __ ] with me I don't
like that negativity is the the want you
know like like the the thing that's
popular is the failure the the [ __ ] up
you know the the fight that I can catch
you know the hateful moment that I can
catch and post like the bad is being
highlighted and celebrated
that's what [ __ ] with me what the
social media [ __ ] now what really
bothers me is you know when you see
these things online like you know a
fight and there's a man hitting a woman
and it's captured right that's bad the
bad thing is that you watched that the
the video was more important than the
actual help right or the moment to step
in and you know when you see these
things where you're catching people do
these things to kids and it's caught the
moment of what you got and what you want
to post and get likes or whatever on is
the focus instead of the help yeah
and that's that's the part that is just
I just have a hard time processing I
have a hard time processing what the
likes mean to certain people well you
get an extraordinary amount of attention
so it doesn't mean anything to you
anyway it means something to a regular
person but you a regular person if they
can catch some worldstar video and put
it up they're like dude that's my video
that's my video
look my video got 5 million hits yeah my
video has gone viral my videos
everywhere for them it's like it's a
point of excitement that's why when they
see you look oh [ __ ] how often are they
gonna run into Kevin Hart at you know
Costco or wherever the [ __ ] you were
definitely running right it to me on uh
you know I'm in a I'm in a bathroom
restaurant and I go to the bathroom you
know by the way that I went to the
bathroom you could definitely tell I had
to [ __ ]
I was I was moving fast I was he knows
one of those abrupt you know why you
eatin
yeah I'm eating bad so I didn't eat bad
in a while my stomach immediately said
that's not gonna happen today I get up
and I go and literally like like three
seconds I hear it as I'm walking or they
go keV hard and as I'm walking by a guy
gets up follows me in the bathroom he's
like yo I gotta get a picture man and I
said let me let me go to the bathroom
when I'm done I'll take a picture with
you I go to the bathroom this is a true
story
hannah bible hand on the Bible I assume
the guys outside the bathroom cuz I as
I'm going I see him and I say what I say
I get done I go to the snake wash my
hand he was just sitting behind a wall
and he's like got his phone out I'm like
he probably did he just take me while I
was [ __ ] dude put the phone over the
thing like I'm about to be on oh my god
it's over this is it this is my
nightmare here we go they're about to
put something up of me shittin is the
bottom of my feet it's whatever yeah but
he just waited and in that moment was so
it was so important that he was in the
bathroom and soon as I got a call on the
second I said let's go outside the
bathroom yeah let's take a picture it's
a bathroom I said might am I going to
I'm a nice guy man I'm gonna take the
picture cuz I just don't want to lose
you and I'm like there's not even a
thought it's not even a thought about
it's a bad price how weird is that
Sebastin minutes this is a this is a
pretty [ __ ] weird moment man this is
weird
Halloween you will be the finish [ __ ] no
no what you got on your phone right
you're too big for me to ask to go
through your phone or whatever you got
you got but I had to go out and take the
picture and I remember going back to the
table just like what's happening that's
not strange at this point what is
happening yeah that didn't exist before
I think if you were famous before people
just wanted to get an autograph or shake
your hand what Pat what passed an
autograph stage was last time you get an
autograph it's been a while I don't
write it I was I think I would know what
to put that it's been a minute man yeah
and I don't want to make this very clear
you know it's not
I don't I don't know you know I
understand like once again I want people
to more importantly understand the fact
that I welcome it
yeah I welcome the moment that I can
talk in and converse with the fame but
it should be that like it's normal
people the moments are better when
they're real you know and after a real
moment you you get a picture because
you're like yo he was actually a nice
guy or I know I did it that you would be
this calm and cool you don't even get to
see how genuine of a person I am because
the first thing you do you you you stick
the camera in the face you and that's
when people think that you're an [ __ ]
because they they they they have the
intrusive moment that then gets met with
the can you keep please I'm sorry you're
not the you look at my face you're gonna
be like that they look for that now you
get your moment yeah you you look for
the negative moment when does it start
getting weird for you but how many years
in um I know it's been it's been pretty
crazy I've been pretty crazy for like
the last four to five the last four to
five years and the last three you know
if it's gotten insane because now you
know you're you're on an international
level its global and the following is is
bigger and it's all ages which is which
is really really good but I think you
know for comedians
it's a different thing because you feel
like you know comedians you know you're
laughing we're in your homes
everything is met with warmth so when
you see a comedian especially if you're
a fan of a comedian you're associating
everything with funny and you're just
looking for the funny moment right
you're you're looking past a normal
moment you know it's like you you almost
are frowned upon if you're normal if you
just chill right right right because
everybody wants the funny moment right
they thought you were gonna be funny
like I'm supposed to I suppose a pop
lock right on the site you know yeah if
it's 2:00 in the morning and you run
into me and I say hey how you doing man
that's not enough when
work out your [ __ ] now mm-hmm I've seen
you at the Comedy Store but only once
where do you work out your [ __ ]
I like to go to random comedy clubs you
know I think I'll go to New York first
New York has always been a home when it
comes to building putting some structure
within a set that you trying to figure
out once I got a skeleton of what I want
to do I'll just go to West Palm I love
that comedy club The Improv down there
and all the place is great I'll stay for
two weeks
Oh real and just go and run through some
jokes I'll go to Utah I'll go to Denver
who do two wise guys yeah yeah yeah I'll
go to comedy clubs just random comedy
clubs that you wouldn't expect to see me
at but I'll do a hell of a run and the
goal is to get out of there with just a
foundation not to have a complete set I
just want to get a foundation so when
I'm done getting the foundation then
I'll do a little comedy club run I'll do
a full comedy club run where I'll just
put two or three months in and it's
comedy club comedy club comedy club and
I'm doing seven shows a weekend and
people are shocked that I'm there and
then I'm doing it but you know that's my
that's my gym that's how I work and I
end up leaving that period of time with
a complete set after the first three or
four months that I spent
now after that comedy club three or four
months on that run then I take it to
like a small theater I see what my
laughter feels like in a small theater
and I do a little run in small theaters
and then when I finally feel like it's
at a point where I'm getting the the
laughs consistently and the punchlines
are working and I flipped it back
frontwards forward every direction and
my story is a real roller coaster and it
has an ending where I feel like we get
off the roller coaster and we're happy
and you don't feel like you were there
for an hour
mmm is then when I go test it out in
every nough and if the arena if the last
er sounds the way it's supposed to then
I say okay I'm ready if it doesn't then
I'll go back to small theaters and then
I'll go to an arena again so not to that
arena sounds the way it's supposed to do
I say I'm going on tour so sometimes it
takes me about a year a year and three
months here in four months you know
people don't say how hard it is to
develop
our of stand-up material people act like
you just turn on a new hour it's it's an
hour to get to an hour you're going
through four to five hours of [ __ ]
that you thought was funny yeah to come
up to that hour that you finally say
this is gonna be the representation of
me this year yeah it's a lot for me to
do that especially at this level you
know well especially while you're always
doing movies and you're always busy with
a bunch of other stuff to stuff yourself
yeah you don't take any breaks white or
I actually you know when I'm touring if
there's a movie I make the movie
schedule around the torso my shooting
days will go Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday rap Thursday maybe ever show
Thursday night and then I'm going
Thursday Friday Saturday sometimes no
show Sunday sometimes show Sunday
depending on what the work schedule and
the workload for the following week
would look like so I'm implementing that
in so when I say I'm out I'm out I'm
gone yeah so I've knocked that movie out
in two months and then when I'm not that
tour schedule shifts so the Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday dedicated the
family dedicated to an office everything
then those weekends are torn but that's
all last for a year and a half I mean
this year we did 157 shows on my
irresponsible tour Wow 157 show before
you decided to put it on the Netflix
special yeah we did the Netflix the
taping I think I did it
three weeks before we were done so we
probably had 143 shows oh wow
then I taped it and finish the tour did
you always have this kind of structure
like when did you how did you design
this thought-out individual yeah I mean
thought-out individual it's not random
no everything is planned if you look at
all my stand-up specials there's a
two-year gap in between them so the
two-year gap is because at the end of
that second year my new special should
be coming out when a new special should
be coming out I'm now focusing on what
the next special is going to be so that
first year is all development like right
now I'm off I'm not touring but now I'm
mentally in the gym and throwing all the
old stuff that I talked about a way
that's now thrown out can't repeat it
can't say it
now it's talking about what the new
version of myself is going to be what do
I want the conversation to be and what's
my thinking and just taking notes so
eventually now I'm gonna start just
popping up a random comedy clubs and
trying to figure out what the next thing
is so by mid mid 20 I'm probably doing
comedy clubs by the end of 20 I have a
full fledge concept of that new hour and
by the beginning of 21 I should be ready
to go out with my new hour hmm end of 21
film my new our mid 22 that hour will
come out that seems like a schedule a
lot of people are doing now the 2-year
schedule it's a perfect get yeah that's
hard dude I know louis c.k did a year
every year and George Carlin did every
year but I think even he said really
wasn't the right way
that's tough a year stuff yeah I mean
that's a that's a shout-out to those
that can't do it I think that's amazing
[Music]
I think just for everything that I have
going on and all of the different things
that my hands are in within the brand
the business I need to make sure that
I'm giving a hundred percent change
those things so they have the highest
opportunity to be successful right if
I'm trying to cheat it then it's gonna
show you know it's not gonna come out to
the best of my ability and with that
stand up you got a you got a [ __ ]
magnifying glass on you you know you're
always being judged off of what you did
at one point just like a musician you're
always judged off of the album that
everybody thought was whatever so the
biggest thing for an entertainer artists
whatever your craft is is creation how
you recreating yourself how are you
constantly showing that you're growing
for me the only way to do that is to
talk about my life and the things that
grow along with me the only thing that
grows along with me my experiences my
family my marriage my mistakes my UPS my
downs those are the things that I can
talk about further because as you get
older things change it gets different
it's all coming from my personal opinion
of me my view on me and how I see Life
you can't lose material in that state
mmm that's why I stay away from certain
things because those things can become
boring after a while for me because I
don't have the knowledge of everything
that I should like what well politics I
don't know joke in the politics I don't
I don't joke and anything that has to do
with the slander of others or other
communities I don't do anything divisive
good for you that's my that's my biggest
thing and you know this past year was
was one that got a little weird because
I was like you know I've really
dedicated myself to breaking people
together like I'm I know that was my my
goal that's my priority I damn sure
thought that's what I was doing
on a global scale everybody all races
shapes sizes whoever you are whatever
you are you can come to a Kevin Hart
show I have a good time so when it came
off as if I was a person that was
divisive that was tough you talking
about the Oscar Oscar [ __ ] yeah this is
a time where people are just looking to
be upset about things a hundred they're
they're not looking to looking at you
Kevin Hart as just a human being like
what who is he who overall super
positive they're not even concentrating
on that I mean think about how positive
you are and yet they tried to
concentrate on some jokes that you did
what nine years ago it was a it's a it's
a wake up call of understanding the
times but it more importantly you know
for me it was okay I went through it I
made sure that the people of the LGBTQ
community really understand it hey guys
I apologized before but I'm apologizing
again I'm sorry I'm not that guy
I don't want you to think I'm that guy
then it just became the constant
conversation there never happened that
it just became the constant conversation
and and now it is guys I'm not only
sorry I don't condone anything that has
to do with hate to anybody this is no
longer conversation so guys I'm gonna
stop talking about it because now I feel
like I'm feeding into yes what
not I I know I'm not the world and
public should understand and know them
not because over this time period I've
shown that I'm not so the apology once
again I'm sorry genuinely I'm sorry
but then it just kept it just it never
stopped and at that point I just made a
decision and I'm like guys at this point
I just I'm making a decision to not talk
about it anymore that doesn't mean that
I'm being disrespectful to anybody that
doesn't mean as I'm shutting down
anything it means that for me I'm gonna
stop talking about it because at this
point I don't know what to do at this
point I thought I thought the apology is
what you wanted me to do I did it I made
sure did you understand that I'm not a
hateful person at Noga don't hate I did
that I stepped down so I don't take
attention off of that night knows people
that are there to be celebrated I don't
want to draw attention to myself and
what's around me I step down everything
I did was for the better of good I'm
stepping away guys because I don't want
this to be a negative night or a
negative thing and then it still became
a conversation so I waited for it to die
down I went on my radio show gave
another public apology
make sure doesn't he understand it I'm
sorry I hope these words didn't hurt
anybody I once again apologized I don't
condone hate to anyone I hope that you
guys can forgive me for those jokes of
oh so now I say if you don't understand
it you don't believe it I don't know
what else to give I don't know what else
to do there's nothing else you can do
that's very wise of you nothing it's
very wise easy to step away like that
because if you didn't they would
probably pursue it forever but I mean
it's it becomes a point of attention
that's all it is it's decided that this
is something they're gonna focus on what
I had a I had a good talk and I'm gonna
talk about this for a minute friend of
mine Lee Daniels you know man Lee
Daniels Lee called me told me where to
talk to you know Lee Daniels is director
producer the show empire's his biggest
shows you know so he calls me he's like
everyone talk to you
and and I was talking he's like look
this is a time where you could speak up
and talk about you know the community
that's been affected by hatred and you
know hateful crimes you can step up and
be a voice and say that you don't
condone or don't stand with any type of
hate or whatever you can take that stage
and do that and I said Lee I said that's
I understand what you're saying I said
well why did you expect me to know
what's been happening with in this
community in regards to hate and crimes
I said I I'm not aware I said some
people can just not be aware I'm not
even no I have no idea what's going on I
have no idea yes within that community I
have no idea right when you tell me this
I'm now educated and I understand so
it's easy to simply inform right
information is key when people get
information they process the information
when you can process the information you
go oh wait a minute that makes sense
hey if you guys think that I can don't
hate wait a minute I don't and anybody
that does [ __ ] you man that's bad you
shouldn't I can say that but instead
when this happened it was become an ally
mmm become a voice you know and that's
that's where there was just a
miscommunication that's where a back and
forth kind of was established that I
think people just started to take things
and run with it
and I'm just not I'm just not one to
feed into what I feel isn't going to
eventually evolve into a positive thing
in a real conversation yes yeah when I'm
trying my best to it was becoming
tabloid [ __ ] as opposed to like a
real discussion click me yeah click
click me that's the problem there's so
much
bait out there because it's such an
effective way to get people to pay
attention to things because as you said
people focus on failure and negative and
anger that's what we want to see
controversy that's what we want to see
people don't want to see the anger yeah
and and you know we think that is
because it's just the times it's it's
that's what's cool now always being
negative you know how you always have
some people it's a great example how you
have people mean you can talk about a
movie all right we can talk about
Titanic wow it's authentic one of the
biggest movies of all time
[ __ ] great movie yes it was great
movie and why guy for no reason go I
[ __ ] hated it yeah why yeah like
Titanic [ __ ] [ __ ] why manga yeah
I know what tell me why'd you hate it I
got time talk about that the cool thing
is just being different I wanna I wanna
be completely opposite Denali Contreras
how the people you know what no no that
[ __ ] was ass what Wow Wow
why was it ass we have people that just
like to do this oh yeah for sure and and
and what happens when one person does it
another person for no reason all go yeah
me too
yeah she was ask man i hain't like it
either did you see it what y'all talkin
about you don't even know what they're
talking about but you just want to hop
on the negative train right because
that's what's cool it's not cool to be
positive it's not cool to be happy I
don't know if it's a cool thing I think
it's usually people that are really
frustrated with their lives
100% what's the that's the factual side
to it I did a joke before was like do
you think Michael Jordan leaves YouTube
comments like people want to get mad and
complain constantly about [ __ ] like that
do you know what it takes to do this
right here you know right here no tell
you how I feel
write in your comments section Joe Rogan
you can kiss my you know what that takes
what do you have going
that you have the time to just simply be
that negative and do it in this world
you know someone's just a mismanagement
of your time yeah it is so valuable and
I don't think people understand how
valuable they can be if they use their
time correctly yes now have you always
been like this always be sausages oh my
[ __ ] god man but always always really
I find a light in every dark tunnel I
will find a goddamn light man I hear at
all you listen when I tell you to wait
on my back it's so heavy of all the
stuff that I deal with and I'm fine the
reason why I'm fine is because I'm
genuinely happy I'm happy and I'm not
happy just because of the success
success X is a bonus I'm happy because I
truly know the definition and the
feeling that comes with happiness I
truly know it I felt it I felt it when I
said yo what really makes me happy and I
look at heaven and Hendrix and I look
his oh I look at my wife I go yo I
didn't have the family [ __ ] when I was
coming up yeah I got one I got one
look what I did look what I built these
people depend on me I provide these
people that makes me happy that makes me
happy when my daughter comes up dad
you're not only my dad you're my best
friend no I'm happy that's my world so
everything else from the outside that
comes in your your your throwing [ __ ] at
a at a at a bubble that can't be popped
mmm it's a force field around me yeah
there's a force field around me because
what matters what really matters loves
me wholeheartedly and when you had that
and you understand that you're
unbreakable so if you don't add to that
force field if you don't make my force
field stronger you don't you don't you
don't get time for me my team heartbeat
productions the people underneath my
umbrella you're part of my force field
you
what I believe we all see the same
things we want the same things
so we march with the same beat you can't
you can't shake that when you're an
individual that seen that and
understands that if you've never felt
that if you have no idea what that feels
like then it's easy to shake you that's
why some people are easily broken being
broken is not a hard thing it's not a
hard thing so those that do get broken
those that do get down those that do get
depressed I understand I understand
I don't I don't knock people for it mmm
I don't not anybody for it what I also
understand is that the encouragement
that can come from so many can add value
for those that may need a little push
hmm that may need a little Amen pick
your chin up
it's so easy to be that positive
reinforcement for somebody and add value
it's so easy but some people choose to
throw that aside and kick while you're
down mmm I try to put out the light of
positivity because whoever is out there
you I don't know what it could do for
somebody else but somebody else may just
simply look at me say you know the way
to he embraces his kids it makes me want
to be a better father
yo way to this man doesn't stop and
await it every day he wakes up and he's
just positive regardless of what's going
on makes me realize that this [ __ ] ain't
so bad the way that he gets up and says
hey today is another day it's the
morning let's all be better than we were
yesterday somebody probably needed to
hear that the more that I can give that
out and I can take my platform to throw
good energy out I'm doing my part
because there's so many that thought the
complete opposite yeah I don't want to
be a part of that that's beautiful man
that's and that's true I believe you
it's not it's not forced right it's not
phony yeah it's not fake this [ __ ] every
day
I hear [ __ ] every day it's very
contagious too I had a lady I heard a
lady right
[Laughter]
lady rolled out a window when you gonna
make a good movie again did you see the
upside was good
what's that oh [ __ ] it's a movie it's
one of my movies that's how us think I
think it's a good movie I see that all
right ma'am you have a beautiful day
that's with such conviction like
literally yeah I could have said a lot
of [ __ ] like she rolled a window down
you could tell she still had the crank
things that I could say to you ma'am
when you gonna make a good movie it's
napping I got one out the upside you see
the outside what's that oh it's a movie
so it's out now amazing it that's how
she chose to come out here I see it I'm
Jesus to come at you with a negative I
get it every day when you'll be funny
again trying my best but trying my best
if it's not working for you hopefully I
do better soon what do you what what am
I gonna feed into that and add water
right why why for what
yeah for what it seems to have been
working thus far are you getting this
positive attitude towards life from life
experience are you getting it from books
did someone teach you how to find this
I'm getting it from the experiences and
from the the real understanding of
perfection doesn't exist don't exist Oh
mmm we're in a time right now where
people expect perfection you expect
perfection I don't know where dust came
from I don't know what happened that
this is the criteria for living
my true understanding is all right you
got one life and then one life the goal
for us is to live it to the best of our
ability from the beginning so what said
the end in the middle in the beginning
middle you're gonna do things you're
gonna make mistakes you're gonna [ __ ] up
you're supposed to learn and then move
forward with the understanding of what
not to do and when you move forward life
may get better it may not but somewhere
along the lines is gonna click and
everything that I went through back here
was supposed to happen so that now that
I'm here I'm able to go ahead with such
a high level of knowledge and I can make
other people better I can make myself
better I could do more for my family
something happens my dad is the prime
example crazy drug addict in and out of
jail life was very bad very [ __ ] bad
my dad son got successful son then took
money gave it to his dad here's your
house here's your truck
here's your monthly at this age I want
you to live your life you know made
mistakes you can't rebuild and correct
the things you've done I'm your son I
love you you can't go back in and redo
you can't try to keep going backwards
ain't about me you got grandkids mmm
gonna be the best grand pop you could be
for these grandkids that's your focus
now where's this energy devoted to being
a grand pop for the grandkids don't
worry about me but something happened in
your life something happened that took
you in the direction to reap the
benefits of your son's happiness and
success my energy is now contagious
nothing I hand it to you so now you're
able to give that off to all these other
people that you're around something
happens and that's in every single life
in every life I understand that there's
a payoff for bad eventually there's a
payoff it can't be bad but for so long
if you got the strength and the
understanding to
realize that [ __ ] will change it will
change it's impossible
just like poker I don't know if you play
poker or not I don't you play poker you
can run bad forever but it will
eventually turn around once you grasp
the understanding of the game eventually
it's gonna turn around
blackjack you're never gonna be the
casino but eventually you're gonna have
a good run if you catch you run you'll
do good get the [ __ ] out of there you
waited long enough for it to happen here
come catch it leave anything in life
will eventually turn good no but this is
coming just from your own personal
experience have any role models that I'm
up to you this way Nancy art did she
speak to you like this about positivity
and about my mom reinforced knowledge my
mom reinforced you don't start things
and not finish them you don't quit
there's nothing that comes out of
quitting besides knowing that you didn't
finish we finish everything you started
finish it if you're gonna do it do it to
try and be the best not be better than
other people
be the best for you if you're in school
and you're going to class I'm not asking
you to get straight A's I'm asking you
to get the best grade that you can
possibly get give me a hundred percent
all the time and I'm a happy mother when
you half-ass me I'm on yes mom I want to
do this I wanna I want to play baseball
well then you gonna play my mom like
that no more then why'd you start the
season because I thought I wanted to do
it then you gonna finish the season you
don't quit there's other people that
invested time and energy into you you
don't just quit on people but I don't
want to do it finish the season mom I
want to swim then you gonna finish swim
it didn't matter what I did I was never
allowed to quit so now in anything I do
when I pick it up a say i'ma start it I
got to finish it it all don't work it
all ate the best hmm it all ain't
knocked out the park but I walk away
saying I finished it I did it
I did it right now I've been boxing I
saw I saw you working out with Rico
Verhoeven I'm [ __ ] first of all very
strong kicker huge man okay he's a big
guy too man good guy but I started in
jeans I started it and I said why am I
doing this I'm not gonna be a
professional fighter I'm not trying to
be a amateur fighter I'm doing the
guiness shape alright then I start
getting shaped I said you know so much
that I don't know about the sport I at
least want to make sure that I'm paying
homage to the people that do this for a
living by really understanding and
learning it you know what I'm gonna get
a real trainer I'm getting some real
people to show me everything so when
it's all said and done and I look back
after my training I can go I gave it
100% and look at how good I got look at
what I'm a product of a spar I go
getting really yeah yeah just to feel it
so I can say it you know well sparse
Bryan Callen is this serious no it's me
yeah that's me come on that's me dude
that's me it's getting it to look at
this
who is teaching him uh his name is Biggs
he's in Atlanta
that's me learn I had a turtle shell
within punches but you know he's a
former Golden Glove guy really good to
you were in a cup and everything when I
was at the sparring session when I'm I
grow tired damn yeah I got touched I got
my ass whipped and every couple times I
go guys worried about that all good I
don't go crazy we had gear and but I'm
not in there with guys that are trying
to hurt yes I'm not in there was
touching guys that have no concept of
reality yeah or control like they're
they're just helping me understand right
here's why you have to keep yeah
that is a problem with celebrities
trying to spar like if you try to like
you know that's why Mickey Rourke
started getting all that facial surgery
I'm serious he's part of James Toney
Jesus lashes she's not a smart right
here that's James Tony's a mean man and
it's just not you can't like I don't I
don't go in that space have you ever
seen James Tony talk [ __ ] boys bars and
there's some of the most entertaining
thing you'll ever find on YouTube he's
just he just won't shut the [ __ ] up
beating your ass he's talking [ __ ]
that's that's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's her and
he's one of the best defensive fighters
ever so he's really difficult to hit
he's got that smells fresh and a in the
world yeah I had a guy who's got any
Mikey I'm sparring with Mikey Mikey hit
me with three punches I thought I
thought Mikey literally had like six
arms this is the true story this I said
I don't know what just happened but I
thought I had my hands up in no matter
where I put him he just tapped me he
lets me feel it but not to where I might
getting knocked out but I understand now
movement I understand pivots I
understand shoulder protection and
that's my goal my goal is just
understand cuz I can't do anything
halfway okay if you try to fight
somebody
nope right nope I just want to say that
I did it and I learn and I can move and
I look the part cuz I put time into it
well as you learn it too as you watch
and you start get trained then you start
to look at a guy like
Terence Crawford or lumen Co and you go
oh now I appreciate what you're doing
because before you'd see like oh yeah I
beat that guy up oh yeah he knocked that
guy out but then you see like how he
ducks under the left and fires back with
the right you know Jesus this is
precision it's insane yeah the the
respect that I have for people that do
that on a day to day is through the roof
yeah and people that fight are in the
most amazing shape in the universe yeah
you're in the most amazing shape ever to
move get hit for three to five minutes
around come back do it come back do it
and these fights go on and on and on I
take my hat off to you
yeah you get three rounds out of me I'm
breathing out my butt I don't know where
the air is coming from I'm searching for
it it's a crazy way to make a living to
money in your brain thank God I don't I
didn't have to go down that route and
you know to those that do just make sure
you just put your body first like you
said it's a it's hurtful when you see
the damage that it can call us yeah we
were talking about that earlier like
seeing guys as they start to deteriorate
and it's hard because nobody wants to
tell him that either every I want to
tell them they got one more good
fighting them and let's uh maybe at the
end of the year then we'll decide but
right now we're gonna train hard and my
stuff it's hard to cuz there's no option
so they don't once you've established
yourself as a professional fighter and
you don't have an exit strategy you
don't know what to do you know now at
least thankfully because of the internet
guys are getting podcasts and they're
starting doing commentary shows they're
talking about fighting and it's the
positive you just found the positive
that's the positive within the internet
that is positive you just don't you just
don't hear it celebrate it as much
well the Internet's very positive for me
I mean this is the show we do on the
Internet
I mean all not just podcast but YouTube
videos and also information I know more
because of the internet than I ever
would have without it there's not a not
doubt in my mind a more educated more
aware person I want just the Internet
yeah you get the things that you're able
to find and search and I mean
like you said you're you're able to
self-educate
yeah at a very high level these are the
goods yeah we're talking about the goods
so when you talk about positive Kevin
how have you been yeah are you always
like that it's this it's the things that
I look at that are so easy you're not
just positive though you're look crazy
ambitious that's the thing that gets me
about you in the rock for sure it's like
the ambitions off the charts like I know
your riches [ __ ] like when when do you
think you got enough you don't have
enough there's no doesn't know enough I
don't have enough because it's not over
it's all over it's not over so you know
when when you put a cap on it you're
putting a punctuation to it mm-hmm and
the the the ambition comes from seeing
what's out there that can be obtained
you know when you see what's out there
like what can you mean physical things
like well you see what's out there when
you see where people are really gaining
wealth and knowledge from okay the
business relationships that you're able
to acquire the people that you're able
to partner with and create certain
things different revenue streams what I
found is as a young black guy from North
Philadelphia the biggest problem with
the biggest problem within our community
is knowledge we don't know debt debt is
welcomed because it's celebrated that's
all we know and I'm get that credit card
oh my [ __ ] that credit card up and it is
what it is they gotta figure that out I
ain't got it after that yeah well you
know what I'm getting student loans they
gave it to me then after that [ __ ] is
I'm figured out I put a cable bill in
your name you put it in my name we can
switch it up whatever they do it there
let's just put it in someone else name
its welcome the Hustle is welcome the
knowledge of banks and what you can do
it can't do is it's [ __ ] you don't
even get it
cuz you go to check cashing places
reason like go check cash place because
I don't want go through that ship the
banks I'll trust that go right there to
check heads please let me get mine let
me get mine now take $30 whatever let me
get it the knowledge is
given so it's not to you obtain that
knowledge and understanding that you go
oh [ __ ] oh this is why you put money up
oh this is this is how you increase
versus decrease oh this is how you earn
on your money oh wow I can gain wealth
by investing in what the stock world is
what how many people partake in a stock
world and is there a part that isn't
necessarily gambling is there a low-risk
part these that's not the information
isn't there so it's not so I got to a
certain level and a certain group of
people where I got it and now that I got
it I want to give it so now I'm going to
give it I'm gonna give it to the people
that I know need it most
and for me that younger generation of
black people that don't understand the
cool thing is in financial longevity not
in a now it's not in the moment for
jewelry not in the moment for the car
it's in the longevity it's in building
so at the end of the day you can say
look at what I have look at what I
worked for look at what I have that's
mine
monopoly is real but you have to have
the financial understanding and I teamed
up I got chased I never done something
called financial fitness where's just
about me educating people on money how
to manage money how to how to be smart
with your money but it's coming from a
person that [ __ ] that money I didn't
always understand it I hold in taxes
before because I didn't understand it in
the beginning I've had bad credit credit
cards wouldn't take me because I maxed
out whatever I've been there I've done
it thank God I was able to fix it and
get on the right path and now that I
have the knowledge I want to give it
could simply don't know so when you say
the end game the end game is getting to
a point where I've taken all the
knowledge that I've been able to get
over these years and really applying it
and providing family wealth when it's
all said and done the last-named heart
is gonna mean just more a lot more than
just Kevin Hart and comedy heart beat
production it's got heartbeat digital
your heartbeat ventures your heartbeat
real estate there's so many things that
the last-named heart will be attached to
you
real estate Kevin Hardin sell real
estate a Bible stand by it but the
reason why is because investment
investment but but as you get older you
learn this you learn it and and you know
it's such a thing where you talk about
black versus white you know a lot of
people do that and and I flee so like
there is racism racism exists I'm not
unaware of that but there is a high
volume of it that's that's non-existent
people had a good people and when you
can merge yourself with good people and
follow the paths that you see that these
good successful people have taken you
then become a part of a world and group
that nobody expected you to be it so for
me I now have the position to do that
and take all of these relationships and
all this knowledge and take it back to
the people that need it most
I like to share I don't want it all by
myself now are you doing this and the
financial stuff you're doing this in
videos you like releasing videos no
we're gonna start we're gonna start
financial fitness like I said with chase
JPMorgan Chase
Jamie Dimon very good guy to Shanda is
well they're there helped leading in
charge of saying how can we get to the
people that we feel need the financial
information of most so I said put me out
there like let's let's go directly to
the consumer so from colleges from high
schools senior classes junior classes
going out and talking to people before
they go into the next stages of their
life a lot of things that you should
know so you're gonna speak to them and
just share personal information are you
gonna put this stuff online as well yeah
yeah you'll be able to track and find
content from it but I'm authentic so I
said the best way to really do it is to
put me in a position to be heard right
I want to be heard like like it's a
different story what I explained to the
the people of JPMorgan Chase just when
we were talking about this and as an
amazing board of people
that are just figuring this out and the
best way to go and do it and I said you
can't have the white guy that's never
been to the hood or who's not from the
hood or has no idea how the economy
works here and what the real troubles
are you can't throw that man in the
situation to talk to people because I'm
not listening to you from the gate
because you don't relate I don't relate
to you but throwing somebody in a
situation that's lived it that's been in
it that's been [ __ ] up in it made it
out of it and is now coming back to help
run it's a different ballgame and that's
what I want to be and you know we have
other voices outside of myself very
powerful voices that are going to do it
as well but the purpose is to align
ourselves to really make a change so you
can either be the conversation about
making change you can be actual a part
of the action to do it I want to be a
part of the action and in doing it
you'll also be able to understand my
drive you'll get why I do so much you'll
get why my hand is in so much because I
have access to it and the question
should be why not yeah the question
shouldn't be yo why is he doing
everything he should be why aren't you
why aren't you trying to do everything
why not well that's the thing about a
guy like you that becomes contagious
like what you were saying about
surrounding yourself with positive
people and people that are constantly
ambitious and that that there's fuel to
that you feel good about that that's
what you're doing
I can I can say seeing you here right we
walked around you show me a facility
loved it beautiful facility you talk to
me about how your podcast is grown to
where you are now the success behind it
I don't leave here and go yo that's dope
of [ __ ] I go hey I need to do more work
on my radio station laugh out loud radio
I own it it's mine I got a show on there
but you know a Joe [ __ ] motivated me
to do more I want to make sure that we
understand really what's out here within
his radio world because I just saw my
guy in his space and I saw happy he is
what success he has I don't want to be
you or beat you
I want to take this energy and apply it
to myself that's the purpose of seeing
yeah that's the purpose of being smart
with your eyeballs you should be a
sponge so I'm a sponge so I come here
and I look at how you maneuver I look at
your setup
I not only bow down and congratulate you
I leave and I said yo man I'm inspired
dude that's dope as hell
John can't wait in two years you gonna
call me you gonna see my [ __ ] you
remember I said I was inspired but
you're gonna see what I let it grow into
that's the proper way to get encouraged
in motivating right as opposed to being
a hater a hater and in competitive yeah
i'ma beat you it's not a competition
yeah I'm not interested in that either
and I share the exact same feelings it's
not a competition at all yeah so if you
don't have people like that that are
inspiring around you you might not know
how positive it is and how it how
powerful it is if you see someone that's
on television or on social media and you
see them it's hard to be inspired you
don't know them but you're I can say
look at your circle right and in your
circle if the conversation is all about
what we hate I can't stay in that song
you see the new [ __ ] car came out okay
this [ __ ] is ass I can't stand that
[ __ ] car yo man I can't stay in this
city what [ __ ] we even in the city what
we eatin I hate that place it's so easy
if you people don't even listen to it
it's so easy to be the smallest [ __ ] in
the world
the smaller [ __ ] but if it's always hate
can't stand these [ __ ] headphones why
we got these headphones ladies like a
horrible day why the buzz here [ __ ] that
Stan it's hard whatever hate harwood how
could you get a private table [ __ ]
hate this [ __ ] [ __ ] chairs you're got
better chairs I hate these chips it's so
easy right so easy it's so easy to talk
about yeah yeah and so many people don't
realize that in a group you do it you
ping-pong hate off on them yeah unless
it's funny it can be funny just between
yourselves trees yeah
Patrice was it was one of the best funny
one of the best
20 haters okay okay you bring up a good
point comedic hate McConaughey yeah
communicate one of the not one of the
probably the best Patrice Patrice I
remember when I would talk and if I was
saying something you just hear what
would you tell buddies what what are you
talking about you like just the way you
talk but what your voice everything
about your voice just makes me want to
punch you in the face
we talking about when he would go after
you - it kind of made you feel good -
like if you're a comments especially if
your comic like I called Opie and
Anthony once I was talking them and
Anthony anything he always has a gun on
him
Harry's a gun everywhere like he has a
concealed carry permit and [ __ ] and I
said to him I said do you ever worry
that maybe you're putting out this
energy and you're manifesting something
like some sort of an attack on you
because you're constantly dwelling on it
you always have this gun and Patrice
goes don't believe in magic don't
believe me conjuring up the world he
would go after you man it's like you
just want to step back and watch I don't
know but he got bill burr so Marilyn Oh
bill used to get so [ __ ] mad
beautiful thing about Bill Barbara would
be snap at bill bill is the guy that's
not funny
where's the punch line in it there's no
punch line he was so [ __ ] mad we the
Comedy Cellar
the days that we had there man bill burr
Patrice O'Neal Keith Robinson Jim Norton
Colin Quinn myself when I say we would
sit at this table we would set this
table for four to five hours
and it would be nothing but beautiful
trash ins to one another when I say they
used to give me so much [ __ ] that's
probably why it's so hard to bother me
now the trash ins that I took from the
age 20 to 24 and my young comedic career
about how awful I was I had a joke I had
a joke where to begin into my career cuz
at the times let me preface this this
was way in the beginning of my career
this was a joke that I had about about
little people midgets at the time and
it's you know it was so bad cause I got
robbed by a cross-eyed Mitch and the
joke was I didn't know he was robbing me
because I was with somebody else so he
was looking at my friend but he was
robbing me it was like a play on being
crisis very very awful joke I remember
telling his joke in a phone book comes
flying on the stage put trees through a
[ __ ] phone book at me I told him this
isn't where the Boston comedy club
people in a crowd tiny little place all
you heard was and you sit back it hits
the floor I said and Patrice said read
it it's better material in it than what
you're saying that crawls does laughs oh
he's uh they all might say they used to
trash me so bad so bad man do you
alleged a retreat some news story a
corporate trees jerking off at my house
before this is I moved to LA I'm saying
the two double partment I just got there
Patrice coming out I said yo you need
place ass I got two bedrooms
you can come near it's my ex-wife at the
time you know I come home it's like
afternoon like Patrice mi yo you all but
tres
but race I go out in the bag open up the
door I said his big-ass computer oh I
see is his back hunched over so baby oil
right and I come in on my door he'll get
out get out get out
[Laughter]
he's so sick he's so sick that he didn't
stop he was so concerned with finishing
then he didn't even break stride and
turn around and not really nothing he
get out yeah you just saw his back
hunched he came out like seven minutes
late it was like my bad i may use come
home [ __ ] for treatment I love him to
death love him to death
yeah he had the most don't give a [ __ ]
of any time I ever met it was most 100%
yeah good and bad yeah you know there
yeah there was a good to it and there
was also some bad you know a lot of
things that didn't have been for Patrese
probably could have happened but I think
the the level of not give a [ __ ] yeah
prevented some of those things well he
was almost too authentic yes like his
like gypsy that was it Charlie Sheen's
roast whose roast was it that he did
what he just torture everybody else on
the roast and then he got up there and
you guys the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] who is
this [ __ ] oh my god Patrice has so many
of those things yeah so many of things
one of one of the best to do it if you
if you are listening you're not educated
I'm Patrice O'Neal just I ask did you
just watch Elvin in the room one of his
specials yeah some of that some of the
funniest [ __ ] ever man and so insightful
mmm-hmm he was so why the way people
thought and behaved he would say [ __ ]
like one of the things that he said that
I I tell people all the time it's a it's
a brilliant thing that he said it was
forget what controversy it was but he
was on television with some woman who
was saying that you should never tell
jokes about certain things you know and
they were they were getting mad at
someone I think it was Opie and Anthony
about a joke and he said you gotta
understand that all jokes come from the
same place the ones you like and the
ones you don't like
the ones that make you laugh and the
ones that make you mad they all come
from the same place someone's just
trying to be funny yeah
like sometimes they just don't work I
had a talk I had a talk with the I
forgot her name I got I forgot her name
but it was when I was doing all the
promo for upside and they kept trying to
break down you know where where where
the jokes come from you know Kevin these
insensitive jokes in that you told back
then why what what makes you why would
you even say those things and the
hardest thing for me to explain I was
like do you think people think of jokes
and while thinking of them think that
they're not going to be funny everything
that you think of in a joke form you're
thinking of it because you think you're
gonna get a laugh behind it
yeah the gamble is if I get the lab
versus not get the lab don't get the
laughs the joke was not funny if I get a
laugh then I guess I'm on to something
there isn't a bunch of thought that goes
into the funny moments that we think may
be great bits yeah I wish that I had a
more logical answer to put behind it I
said I don't especially at that time my
career I just thought it would be funny
the same way that some people think sir
jokes funny the offer it's a thought
comedians are constantly throwing [ __ ]
out there yeah you're constantly rolling
a dice and Thor [ __ ] out there had to
[ __ ] you roll and good right it's not
gonna be good the other hatten maybe all
right maybe kind of good but it's all
with the intent of entertaining it's not
with the intent of being malicious it's
not with the intent of sparking hatred
it's all trying to make you laugh yeah
that's it like it's it's literally that
simple from a thought within the
comedian's mind yeah
nothing nothing else
they kept trying to look for this like
hard definition of why and it's like I
don't have it I don't have the reason
why I thought it would be funny and it
wasn't that's the downfall
that's it that's it it's it's and the
thing is about this art form is that up
until ten fifteen years ago there was
never any discussion like this it wasn't
so so when we developed and when we were
coming up there was no it was just like
and there was always guys that would
push the envelope way too far I believe
Jesus Christ you see his new bid what
the [ __ ] yeah and you'd be laughing yeah
you tell it to each other and yeah and
it didn't matter what it was joke about
murder or rape or what some people just
use those dark subjects like they're
trying to make us laugh yeah in the
meetings the comedian's comedian there's
always gonna be though well you just
innovate you all do you know Brian
Holtzman 100% yeah but in Holtzman's
that guy 100% my funniest dudes and and
and there's no way that I could say no
some of the stuff that I heard me say
remember Susan Smith that lady who
drowned her kids I I know I know who
you're talking about her and I know the
moment but I'm not familiar with all all
that involved Holtzman was on stage that
week and he's like I heard those kids
were bad I heard they set that close to
the TV they never put away their blocks
there we spilt their milk those kids
will not be missed
yeah and you were just like oh I in the
[ __ ] like 9/11 when 9/11 happened they
wouldn't let him on stage
well Mitzi shore would not let him on
stage four months after 9/11 she's like
no way keep him off the stage I mean do
you have you have the people just Sartre
did they go for that they go for because
they want to hear you howl and get back
to the room do you know that like if
it's you know comics are there in the
back of the room they're gonna laugh
their [ __ ] ass off at that chair and
and you know it's weird because right
now within a times I'm the comedian that
chooses to be sensitive to the times you
know I've made the choice to say I
understand
I get why you shouldn't say certain
things why you should avoid this that or
this I I understand and I am but then
there's other comedians that go you know
what I'm more staged I'm gonna be me and
I'm not gonna do that because people are
telling me that this is what I I'm gonna
go harder yeah and do that that's yeah
that just exists it just exists but I
think it's easier to just say I'm not a
fan that comedy isn't for me
right you know what I don't I don't like
the taste of this particular comedian so
I'm not going to support a watch that
comedian I'm gonna find another comedian
there's more to my liking I'm going to
go and just turn my head like I want us
to get back to just understanding that
you just don't have to support it yeah
that's it well there's a lot of [ __ ]
option it's very I mean there's so many
today
yeah there's never been more never been
more comics I think about how many
people were doing Netflix specials so
many's never been more it's something so
easy so I don't understand why there's a
push to destroy which you just don't
have to support it like I think it's
just a bunch of people that have an
ability to influence things now that
didn't have an ability before and it's
like they see a window and they want to
throw a rock it's right there makes
sense I think there's something that but
I also think mm-hmm for us like meat for
me in particular I really like [ __ ] up
comedy
it's one of my fits like I like Quentin
Tarantino movies where people get shot
and killed yeah I don't want anybody get
shot and killed in real life yeah but I
like [ __ ] up comedy yeah do you know
Tim Dylan is yes I do pull up that
[ __ ] video that him being mega Kane
he is a savage dude he goes so hard but
I saw this video I was tears rolling
down my eyes I was crying and I was like
okay this guy's needed we need this
right now because during this political
correct push you got this big giant gay
dude who doesn't give a [ __ ]
let me seize an animal watch this [ __ ]
and we're going to it will be raised in
captivity it'll be raised privately to
be the greatest politician that has ever
had my name is Megan McCain and I'm on a
new show we have you see this to folks
that [ __ ] riverboat casino catherine
is talking about my father again
my father was tortured for a hundred
years for this [ __ ] country and he
came back and he started seven wars
because he's a gentleman
[ __ ] you try I'm gonna wear my father's
skin mask and I'm gonna primary from the
right if you don't know he's wearing
lipstick and a dress oh my goodness
that's pretty damn that's out there they
need that guy we need him it's out there
we need guys like that I mean just
talking about what we said it's like
it's just it's very easy to just to just
say you know what that's not me behind
what is like for me yes advice humor is
different I laugh I laugh there's a
rhythm there's a viral video it is this
old guy trying to hoverboard he's like
[ __ ] he's gotta be like 69 70 and you
know his grandkids there and he's like
let me let me try it let me try it and
this man gets on this hover
board and takes if you saw Mike Tyson
fall on a hoverboard his fall was worse
than Mike Tyson's I've never seen
somebody hit their head harder in my
life and I didn't laugh out of wanting
to see this old man hurt herself I
laughed because it was stupid to try to
get on his hoverboard in the first place
and when he got up he tells the kids why
is it moving like this this video
everybody because that [ __ ] made me
laugh some people were watching
oh no no some people were watching to go
oh oh oh another one just died [ __ ]
laughing because everybody's humor is
different yeah humor is different my
humor is different falling makes me
laugh okay we're you are falling makes
me laugh I don't give a [ __ ] who you are
if you fall in front of me no shot I'm
holding there laughs there's no shot you
don't stand a chance
if you there's no shot that I'm not bust
your ass something something's got to
come out right falling is funny I still
think it's hacky I still think farts are
funny when my kids fart I laugh I still
to this day it's the funny [ __ ] every me
that goes that V you stick get out of it
stay gas my little son 17 months when
you fart I laugh something something
within just ability to just be [ __ ]
silly and GOP oh yeah it doesn't always
have to have a meaning behind it some
[ __ ] is just stupid my eight-year-old
farts on cue she thinks it's hilarious
genius she'll tell you that listen I
gotta talk to you about something that's
laughing she think it's hilarious she'll
fall down the couch she can't stop
laughing that's all you got it's your
only bit as a kid nothing else but farts
that's all you got that's all you've got
to make people laugh you should enjoy it
no he should think it's funny folly but
falling is number one for me
falling is number
one my wife fell down the steps she got
so mad cuz I didn't rush to help her I
laugh she had a wine glass wine with all
over the walls oh my god what are the
worst Falls I've ever seen in my damn
lap got up her shoe was on one step the
shoe was all follow us funny I like it I
don't laugh have fallen that much I just
deal with too many injuries I've seen
too many people get hurt it's not for
you yeah especially old dudes fallen
down hitting their head on Mike I start
thinking about brain trauma and CTE
long-term repercussions I'm near I'm
right there with you it's probably
better I'm right there with you there's
the one that's going on today of this
dude trying to come up the stairs on
this other dude did you see that one the
guy stomped them and set him flying like
all I could think of is we don't see it
in the video but that guy's head it's
got to be smithereens oh my god he he
had hit his head the way he fell back
yeah you ever seen one of the guy who
slipped and fell down a bunch of steps
at the museum and falls in the water
yeah he's going it goes in water Dumbo
right you can't you can't beat that
there's this dude this goes walking up
the stairs and this dude's legs get the
[ __ ] off my porch stop leave me alone
and he keeps coming he's like don't do
it don't do it and he got boom smack the
way he fell back you know hands behind
him that's all head that's all head
first of all to not see that kick coming
yeah from a guy that says it's sad but
you also have to realize a guy that size
is carrying all that weight of a donkey
kick yes
that's just caved in my got stomped but
to not see it once again I always
thought that about fat people but if you
really really fat imagine how strong
your [ __ ] legs must be strongly
should ever yeah if you really get some
power behind that kick and also if
you've lost the weight you'd have these
incredible legs that's a that's always a
theory just it's Anthony
but I was wonder if their needs are
gonna shrink it wait what because you
see someone from behind they're like 500
pounds like their knees are that wide
I'm like okay is that the bone like is
that fat around the bone like has the
bone grown really wide too cuz your body
does your bones do get denser if you do
like heavy weight mmm like this if you
look at like power lifter dudes they're
do they're dense well part of it is not
just their frame it's that they're
constantly lifting heavy things so your
body thickens up did you as you go but
you know when when you know people that
are larger make the the dedication to
actually losing the weight and they stay
away from like the weights and stuff and
just do cardio it sheds off so fast yeah
but he can't like I know I know a couple
of friends of mine and lost like 130 140
pounds and like if now just fallen in
love with fitness to the point where
it's unbelievable like how their body is
transformed and taking a liking to the
new the new process that they're now in
pretty yeah they get addicted instead of
food they get addicted to being healthy
exactly it's totally possible totally
possible I've had I don't know how many
people come up to me and said they've
lost a hundred pounds plus because of
listening to my show and having fitness
experts on and diet experts and and just
talking about staying the [ __ ] away from
sugar say don't eat late at night yes
that's eating stop eating in a certain
time and give yourself more than enough
time to digest Cal your calories start
exercising well with me I think the
thing with me that helps me so much as
I'm not a foodie you're not I'm not a
foodie man I'm just not you know it's
boring gotta go eat with I'm just making
a Turk that's it I'm literally just what
is that yeah that's fine let me give
that this baked chicken some brown rice
that's fine I'm good you don't worry
about eating healthy I'm a healthy eater
because I'm not a foodie so it's not
like it doesn't doesn't matter like I
don't have the will or want to eat the
bad [ __ ] so if you're passing by
in-n-out burger nothing no nothing nah
man I'm black fried chicken fried
chicken you showed me a process Popeyes
Roscoe's is good too but Popeyes really
pops with Roscoe's yes man paradise
Popeyes is [ __ ] I don't know what I
don't know what's in that chicken better
pretty damn good that's why see damn it
do you like the spicy spicy set my ass
on fire but I'm still gonna do it
yeah I'm still gonna do it but I'm just
not I I can consistently eat the same
thing and be fine
how is Popeyes the only one who figured
out that red beans and rice is a great
thing to have on the side no one else
has it it's the best thing ever
you know me why doesn't Burger King or
McDonald's pop ha red beans and rice
Popeyes is so good so good that when I
was younger I was about 22 I was on a
bike I got hit by a car right not too
hard to where I was damaged but I had
Popeyes in my hand like the bag I was
riding on on my bike and holding it one
hand bop got hit never let go to the bag
Wow
that's how good Popeyes is the bike
everything else boom I'm there Popeyes I
held on to it nothing was damaged still
took home finish that meal that's in
crud that's how good Popeyes is 100% so
that's my cheat my cheat is Popeyes all
day other than that I'm a consistory
thurr
I'm healthy guy so Dee take vitamins or
supplements or anything I used to take
multivitamins which inspired me to start
doing my home like right now we got
bicycle okay I'm starting my own
supplement line vitae hustle love to
vitamin that we put out but let me tell
you why doe I'm gonna tell you why I'm
even getting into this space so when I
look at physical fitness and I look at
this world I noticed that you know you
have a you have a great one in need to
look like everything around you that you
see like everybody like everybody that's
a part of this world they look so
[ __ ] great and fit when they're
talking about these products and the
things they can do and I said you know
what what I'm able to do and what I've
done in my past I'm always bringing
people together of all like in whole
like there is nobody's alienated you
know when I did my runs with Nike and
before I got signed by Nike it was about
bringing a bunch of people that never
ran before
and getting you guys to get up just come
run with me just try it and you notice I
got people out that never thought they
were [ __ ] do it and we doing five
miles
we don't ten miles whatever it's just a
group run something to say we did I said
how can I create a product where I'm
putting people in a position to
understand there's a hustle in all of us
that's what my multivitamin is about
it's the energy is the recharge it's the
ability to focus is to approach your day
with all of the tools that you basically
need it's not just about the physical
fitness aspect it's about the health so
if I can actually motivate people to
take the step in the right direction of
health with a line of supplements that
are driven for the everyday individual
that may not know or be aware but wants
to engage but you're not in it to look
like all these different people you're
in it to be the best version of yourself
how can I do that
teamed up with a great group of people
to create the best possible products
that I want to do and I said I want to
be patient so it took me for you four
years to create about us and how many
different products you go right now just
by dose vitae Hustle is my only one
right now so it's just a vitamin just a
multivitamin but it's an amazing
multivitamin is it a single pill or is
it a packet but no it's a it's a jar I
should have [ __ ] bought one good job
a jar Jesus Christ so you like mix it in
some stuff no it's a jar full like all
pills
yes pills okay um I'm gonna tell you the
dope stuff this that's in it cuz I don't
want to not say anything in and have it
to where it's wrong so I always got it
up on the screen man good Jesus Christ I
get it hey you guys see it yep that's
why you here we're gonna save that on my
phone blueberry fruit extract scroll
scroll back up there boron biotin
beta-carotene vitamin A mmm-hmm what's
all good [ __ ] it's all good [ __ ] it's
more than a multivitamin I'll plan him
in a it's good II
what does that stuff Toco Toco trend all
teletran out talk--i channels vitamin E
family mm-hmm-hmm you ever heard of that
Jim vitamin K look it up alright look it
up
it's a good thing too is that everything
that's in it you know it's not only is
it researchable but you'll see why like
my biggest thing like as a guy that's
not as familiar with the space I said
who are the people that are they do it
at a high level that I can incorporate
into helping me build this product so I
feel like you're never gonna do it by
yourself you shouldn't try to do by
yourself and you don't cut corners you
don't go to cheap route you don't you
don't do it wrong something you have to
go back to do it again Brian so I went
and I looked at the people that were
involved with creating the quote-unquote
best markets the best things on the
market and I put that team together I
put up a team like four to five I'm
gonna tell you for years spent a lot of
money developing this [ __ ] because it
wasn't right in the beginning had to go
back had to do it again wasn't right had
to go back find out the other things
they made other things better of things
great had to go right go get it again go
try it go do it again
not right what else is out there what
are we compared to until I felt that now
when I launch there's going to be a
place for my product in the market where
people will understand that is exactly
what I said it was there's no lying
there is no you know false presentation
behind the product Kevin Hartz
multivitamins much more than
multivitamin but more importantly it's
something for everybody
and more importantly it's to spark the
hustle within all of us and it's the
first there will be more but it'll be
after I've mastered and done this at the
highest level then I moved to product
number two then I moved to product
number three before you know it you want
to see a [ __ ] whole line that Kevin
Hart is slowly developed and that people
can actually believe in because I'ma be
a product of my own product that's the
best thing in the world when you're a
product of your product has to work for
me before I say it's gonna work for
everybody else so you take this stuff
goddamn right I take it how long am I
taking it I spent all this [ __ ] money
I better take it
I've been taking the the one that's
launching now for about five to six
months nice I've been taking this one
I'm very happy because I actually feel
the difference and the difference is
just in the energy that you have with
him day it's not an energy [ __ ] pill
but I do feel a difference in my
in my ability to last throughout my day
like I'm I do a lot man I do it [ __ ]
light so I told you I'm starting at that
final 5:30 and I'm not shutting down to
let 9 10 I saw a video once where you
were taking a video of your your trainer
passed out yeah like this lifestyle
everybody very unattractive sleeper by
the way shots out to Tim boss Ronald
over line and one of the worst sleepers
you have a seat so you take him with you
everywhere yeah my trainers let me
everywhere Wow everywhere so you train
every day every day Wow every day
Sunday's are light days like cardio
maintenance is what we call it not doing
the same thing all the time we switch it
up
love switching about love finding new
things within Fitness to make it fun you
never want to get bored within it so
your your whole purpose is just to keep
your vitality up keep your energy up
just to keep it it's if I don't do it
then there's a lag I need to train I
need to do it because I I'm mentally so
invested in it now that when I don't do
it I feel like I've cheated myself in a
in a day or a week that I've taken off I
feel like yo man I'm not myself because
when I am doing it I feel like I'm
always I'm committed I'm committed to
constantly building and reshaping and
molding I'm working on me so when I'm
not working on me I don't feel like my
day that's supposed to be about me it's
starting off with the biggest bang right
this is my advantage to starting off
like nobody else my day starts off
before [ __ ] worms and birds get up
I'm we're time to get up five five and
that's when you start working out Jim
5:15 5:20 really 5:15 5:20 no food I
don't eat I don't need before workout
yeah I'm not I'm not I eat it before I
workout never had didn't know what I am
now because I'm getting older I'm more
conscious of my body so I'm big with
sports massages I'm big with you know
making sure that
I'm not putting myself in a position to
get injured and overwork right so
getting stretched you know trying to to
do as much movement that as I possibly
can like when I say I'm a little walking
muscle I really AM so my flexibility is
limited so right now that's my biggest
focus so I'm about to start yoga trying
to do that things that can just kind of
keep me in a position to to not tighten
up so I don't pull anything cuz I do so
much are you gonna do hot yoga yeah do
that [ __ ] all the time do you roll it
love it amazing do it every week yeah
only thing that's kept me from doing it
is the smell and it's possibly you never
that's the only thing that's kept me out
of it
I was like you gotta move past that yeah
blessa I hear I get pretty bad sometimes
it can yeah the place I go to is nice
you just gotta make sure that the people
take care of themselves well you know
he'll be around smelly people I'll be
honest I'm worried about myself I don't
know what I'm gonna get especially if
you get there early in the morning you
know eat you won't worry about farting
yeah but the people that eat breakfast
yeah go they are letting off and
everything I'll explain that the killer
Mikey was talking to me about farting in
yoga class I'm the guy can't be eating
no can't be eating before that early are
you going I like to go either 6:00 a.m.
which is rare most of time 8:00 8:00
8:30 depends on where which place I go
to - but you love it though yeah it's
great for your head - it's 90 minutes of
suffering you know it's hot it's [ __ ]
you hundred five degrees hundred four
degrees when you get out of there you
feel like you did something really yeah
and it just changes the way your body
feels - in terms of your range of motion
your flexibility all those weird
connecting knots and everything just get
opened up and you know my question is
when you when you're just starting no
yeah like like I will be is it extremely
tough and a beginning again you just
just gotta bring a lot of ice water
just bring a big ol [ __ ] 64 ounce one
of those of you know thermal flasks of
ice water make sure you have enough
water and drink enough water before it
I'm talking put me in a bag yeah just
start now I don't need to be what people
could see me just we got like a section
in the back yeah well you turn left you
turn right everyone's gonna see you yes
I'm saying can I be in a place where
they go
see me in the beginning like I don't
want anybody to see you're athletic man
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
tight it's gonna be difficult for you to
pull off certain poses but you'll be
fine I'm definitely gonna do it I'm
definitely realize it's a challenge I'm
definitely 100% gonna try your [ __ ]
would you do too no that's next
yeah that's next Justin I'm just on here
listen this is where Rico was laughing
because I say oh man don't laugh
annotators I've never thrown a kick as I
said whatever you show me right now is
my first time doing it I don't I don't
kick I don't know how to kick right so
whatever you show me this is this will
be me processing it for the first time
and that day we did it we worked on and
I think I threw a couple good kicks a
couple good front kick and I said I said
look after I'm done with boxing I said
this will be my next test to learn how
to probably throw some kicks and to move
with my bottom half now that I've worked
on my top that's my next hobby that's
your next time you know jiu-jitsu is
like that's the tough one in choice and
you want to do that too I'm just this
stuff as you get older you have to find
[ __ ] to do right if you don't find [ __ ]
to do you won't lose your mind you would
get addicted to that I just wanna learn
[ __ ] you would like it because there's
so much to learn that's the thing about
it it's a long long never ending never
ending never ending journey of [ __ ]
there's also there's so many different
variations of each different individual
move and entries into new moves and
defense and then the structure of it is
it's it gets so crazy it's it's super
complicated my son my son does a my son
is heavy into boxing in karate I got him
meant to those so he he does them both
so the reason why I want to do I just
like to keep up with him so we can you
know do things together
I have trainers come to the house and
we'll work out together he loves it so I
just don't want to get left behind that
you know we get 1718 which we'll say
Dave I don't want that but we better
back up when they start getting that
much confidence I just want to be able
to keep up and maintain so that's why I
like to do it with them well it's good
for a kid to to have that in your head
which is not a defense
confidence yeah you need that for
confident it'll help you avoid things
too well I tell my kids you know your
last name puts a target on your back
that you didn't ask for and we don't go
and create problems but you should
always be prepared for problems if they
were to occur and if they do I just want
you guys to know how to defend yourself
so the things that I have my kids doing
it just have the knowledge and
understanding the worst thing is just
not knowing you know they're growing up
completely different than I grew up
where I grew up you had no choice but to
know if you ain't know how to fight
that's your ass cuz you're gonna get
tested there's no way around it you're
gonna get tried you're gonna get robbed
you're gonna get your bookbag take it
it's am I gonna try to take snakes like
it's the reality it's not a false
reality that's real so if you're not
prepared for it if you don't have any
type of heart you won't last from where
I grew up heart was everything and heart
was sometimes saying I don't care if I
get my ass whooped I'm not gonna be a
[ __ ] I'm not gonna I'm not gonna lie
y'all to think that this can't happen so
I'm gonna lose today but tomorrow I'm
gonna complain and imma firin you imma
talk whatever that moment was it was
about establishing any level of respect
that you could and I respect the
eventually turned into friendship from
all so my kids don't know what that
world is like they're never gonna have
it so as a parent I just have to make
sure that you have all the tools that I
can possibly equip you with because my
president have the ability to provide me
with it they weren't a financial space
to to take me here and have this extra
curricular activity or this extra
curricular activity or learn it learn it
then exist
that is the big conundrum of successful
Hebert can actually when successful
people have kids the what made them
successful is dry I grew up poor too we
were on welfare and food stamps the
whole deal when I was a little kid and
that always stuck in my head this
thought like we might not have enough
food like I remember thinking that when
I was a little like what if we don't
have any food what if we run out of food
my kids will never feel that they don't
understand what that is and everybody
that I've ever met that's interest
came from some crazy struggle yeah when
they were young yeah and that's the
thing of your you and I and most people
that are doing well in life you're
raising your kids in a completely
different way then literally what
brought you to the dance and the first
that's the hunger of not being one of
those people that's left behind is what
makes you successful in the first place
and it's scary it's scared because you
know my wife my wife told me she was
like you know I love that you're not
hard on your kids but you always make
sure there's a lesson within your
conversation like I don't yell I'll yell
at my kids
nothing's gonna register when I'm
yelling so I tried my best to talk to
you everyone I met my angriest
I'm gonna talk to you so you can process
this because you need to understand
what's the problem you need understand
what's wrong and what I had to really
realize is they didn't ask to be born
into this yeah you know I mean like that
it's not their fault right that they're
coming up completely different than how
we were raised right and we can't have
anger or frustration that's dedicated
and thrown towards them because they got
it so much better than what we had how
do we make sure to be passed down to
proper lessons so that they appreciate
and understand and not take for granted
right they have right for me it's tough
because good kids good students their
plot themselves in school they listen
they don't do dumb [ __ ]
yeah they want to play video games and
stay up like any other kid there's no
signs of a bad or crazy yeah and the
fear and panic is that you got a note it
bad and crazy exists right this fairy
tale day we're in isn't real and at some
point when I'm not around when your
mother's not around when you have
friends or other family on around you
may get tested with the other side
that's out here that you've never seen
right so I gotta prepare you for the
[ __ ] that you don't know exists I gotta
take you to Philadelphia so you can see
I try to show my kids where I grew up
thinking that's going
be like oh my goodness backfired
it's so cool can we live here shut up
[ __ ] you told my everybody here the car
right now around you talk like this move
your back this does not go well supposed
to oh my gosh so cool dad is so
different oh my goodness walked him
around a neighborhood and it's like it's
it's it's not a reality you didn't have
grass and that's dad oh that's great
would you play why were you here yeah
when you hear these things it's so
different man these were your steps the
steps are broken how did you even play
oh my god dad so wait we're weird was
yours we lived on the top floor not the
whole thing
no it's this is three separate units so
the top floor was me and grandmom's the
middle that was somebody else that was a
neighbor and downstairs or somebody else
three different people lived in this one
thing together y'all with strangers my
own hands I don't know I don't know
what's say it this part yeah right in
the car but but when you see that that's
the reality that you get hit with of I
gotta make sure that I'm talking I gotta
make sure that I'm constantly teaching
yeah if I'm not and I'm not doing my
part
I'm failing you know took them to the
neighborhood and showed them how stores
are in the neighborhood it's what we got
candy from here's here's what we would
get little sandwiches from y'all walk we
don't have no stores like this we can't
walk this stuff it's a completely
different world
well it's a completely different world
see people stand on the street corners
what they doing they're big they selling
drugs that's that's tough right there
those are people that your dad still
knows they've been there forever that's
what you don't want to do but they're
forced with these decisions just because
of what they have to do you just need to
see this dad is taking you here to see
this drove them all around all around
North Philadelphia all around South
Philadelphia made sure they could see
yeah physically see we go out the
country we go to these resorts and
islands before we go they're gonna drive
around so you can see what exists before
you get to this this is why we have to
be good people this is why we treat
everybody with respect this is why your
dad likes to give everybody doesn't have
I'm constantly beating my kids with that
information because if you assume that
everybody does you come off like such an
[ __ ] when you're around people that
don't yeah like how did you you don't
also the advantage that they had growing
up the way they are now it's such a rare
thing and they don't understand it
there's no way there's a small
percentage yeah a very small percentage
and that's something that I never want
to let go of either so I was in the back
of my head are you talking about how you
know are we gonna have enough food you
were coming up Chris Rock's joke is so
great that he used to tell the hi he
keeps a bag packed at the front door cuz
he don't believe that this [ __ ] is his I
truly believe you thin at any point
somebody gonna go gotcha you thought you
lived here did you visit joy and I was
like it's so real because even though
you have it you can't lose the sight a
reality of where you once was yeah do
you are you comfortable where you are
now or do you still have those thoughts
like this is this real because you
you're at this stratosphere of Fame and
success that's it's rare amongst the
rare hmm you know it's like David Goggin
says you are uncommon amongst uncommon
men I will be a hundred percent honest
and say I'm comfortable with the
understanding of hard work brings great
rewards this is a reminder of the hard
work and dedication that I put into
everything that I've done I'm not
content because I know where I came from
and I don't ever want to go back
that doesn't mean I don't want to go
back to the city that doesn't mean I'm
gonna go back to the people that means I
don't want to go back to living like I
once was I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna
help I want to inspire what a motivate I
want to show people that there is a way
out that there is a way to do more to
get more to obtain more but I personally
don't want to lose all that I've been
able to get so I need to make sure that
I do everything to keep it so I can't be
content mmm so there is an understanding
but I refuse to click on the switch of
so even if you like even if you have
more money than you'll ever spend for
the rest of your life that's not what
it's about it's about the inspiring
people and the influence and constantly
giving back and moving forward in a
positive way and the only way you can do
that is to stay active it's the story
man yeah you know we're we're all
writing a book what's your book look
like mmm what is your [ __ ] book look
like like your life is a bulk you got a
bunch of chapters in your book but when
they closed that book how good was the
book how good was your book what was the
ending to your book if the ending to my
book can be so amazing because of all
that was done the money all that was
accomplished the first to do the man
that did this he caused a merger between
this because of his commitment and
growth to this the communities were then
given this made education this changed
the way the schooling was Baba Baba gave
books gave computers gave all of the
things that can be associated with you
and your existence become a part of the
chapters in your book so my drive is
about my book I was a New York Times
number-one bestseller
people will be done they did it I'm
writing another book
you ready to vote right now yeah what's
it happened what happens if you are to
Tom
New York Times number-one bestseller if
you get the two what happens if you get
the three hey man how do books become
successful who publishes them I want to
start a publishing company heartbeat
publishing why not mmm that's the thing
all I'm doing is sparking the awareness
and others to go why might why can't I
create why can't I start why can't I be
a business why can't I be a CEO why
can't I be a tech guru why can't I
[ __ ] create cooking products lotions
since there's so much that some people
just don't understand they can do let me
be a spot to show how much how many
different you don't have to do just one
thing when it's all said and done my
book is gonna be full of all this [ __ ]
that Kevin Hart did cuz I never was
content with doing just one two or three
why not
Kevin why are you creating [ __ ]
health and wellness products why not
I'm big on health and wellness why can't
I why can't I try to create something
that I filled is [ __ ] great and jump
into a space that I'm already in I
already give a hundred percent of me in
this space why not why can't I talk
about financial wealth why can't I go
back and educate those that don't know
why not you got time I make time well
you certainly can but it's just so
unusual that someone dedicates that much
energy and time to giving back and
getting involved with the kind of
projects that you're talking about as
well as be super ambitious with your own
career it makes me happy yeah I could
tell I'm genuinely happy discovery makes
me happy like when you find different
things to be excited about it makes me
happy and it's weird when it clicks and
schooldays to tell you all the time
information is key read these books
there's so much knowledge [ __ ] that book
time to read that book I want to go home
goddamn Sonic the Hedgehog I want to
play I'm at level 3 I got something to
read this book the information is stuff
there it was
forced down your throat at a certain age
you just you just may not be receiving
it correctly but then it clicks you may
gain information differently and what
you do with that information is up to
you but people people have different
roles they can go down the education
wasn't my pick of choice it didn't do it
for me but the knowledge in the common
sense that I have naturally allowed me
to gain information apply it differently
it allowed me to grow smarts in so many
different avenues to where I said oh my
god I found my niche I found my talent
and now there's other things that my
talent can take me to I don't have the
all the knowledge and awareness but I
can allow myself people to do that can
teach me because now guess what learning
is cool ya know what happened you don't
have to do it anymore right it's its own
you're a kid they force you into this
school you don't want to learn but then
when you get out and you realize like oh
this actually benefits me does it make
me a better person this makes me wiser
it's 100 percent dirty and it's weird
how it happens but when you go oh my god
learning and knowledge is power mmm [ __ ]
they used to tell me this when I was 10
my quads yes mom sons 10 11 years old I
heard that [ __ ] all the time now I
finally get it
damn I'm about to be 40 took me all this
time to get the goddamn code but I got
it yeah
it hits you at a different time mm-hmm
and when it does be excited about it man
you excited I'm excited about what 50
years I'm just now getting to 40 do you
read books I don't read a lot of books
do you listen to books on tape I have
listened to books you know what let's do
what Tony Robbins he's great Tony's a
like I like his approach to giving
information mm-hmm I like his attitude
in general I like podcasts
I like things that are real and out of
presented in front of me
I like information that I can go to the
source and and touch and talk so I'm I
and I'm reading a book it's a book that
was recommended by such-and-such and the
person who gave it to me and that's
reading that book I learn more about the
individual that I thought I already knew
and now I gain more
Michelle Obama's book great book great
[ __ ] book I met her I talked to her
I've been in the same rooms I've seen
her success
what is her book gonna be about mmm or
read a book
Wow I get it I get wise moving all the
units that it's moving
I get why women are reading his book and
walking away feeling better feeling like
they can't I get it oh wow
hmm certain friends Dwyane Wade wrote a
book focused on being a father his road
to becoming a better father what he went
through with his kids mother
he developed a relationship than a bond
with his sons like nobody else Wow
didn't know that day that's dope I love
how you put it on page there's certain
things that you just want to know
certain books help I understand why
people read books I get what the
information does you know the book that
I'm working on now is all about the
mental approach that you have with life
and people not understanding that your
biggest enemy is you my whole book is
about you battling yourself people to
understand is you against you the only
person that gets in your way is you
nobody else is you now when you write a
book like this and especially about
something like this this is like the way
you've managed to navigate through life
mm-hmm are do you do you write it out in
essays do you do you do you have like
bullet points that you you think about
and then once you have those bullet
points you had then you write on those
how do you do it
get on your phone it's all all voice
notes and transcripts okay so because of
your time you don't have you don't have
the the time to sit and actually write
mm-hmm so you need somebody that you can
talk to for hours hours hours on it hey
I need a hour but I gotta holler for me
I got some stuff we want to talk to you
about keV what what's that all right
book title ideas subtitle ideas my
dedication is my introductions within my
introductions these are all powerful
paragraphs and things that I was just
said that are now transcript I get to go
back and read it
come see here there's no conversation at
all every one of them um no conversation
all and that's what the Internet has
allowed people to do Internet has
allowed people to skip steps 1 through
30 as a lot of people to jump straight
to 100 [ __ ] you good job off take them
down you should be dead oh god [ __ ]
can't stand this whatever the hater the
anger is when listen when listen ok when
I listen and I can change I'm not that
guy we're doing these weird things now
that people aren't taking the time to
sit and think through what I've
understood is that what people are doing
has nothing to do with me I should
always be a step ahead because I'm
thinking differently because I'm
thinking about myself making myself
better puts me in a position to make
others better be the example not the
problem
the best way to take away the problem is
to a lien 8 yourself from it these are
business thoughts oh it's [ __ ]
thought I can go through and just read
this is a so you just have these
philosophies of your life and you just
just speak it listen just speak it dance
so now this is all chance capable
Columbus's that's incredible there's all
[ __ ] transcript this is all Sarge's go
back throughout the day and I read it
and I say this is great this makes sense
this didn't let me reword this I mean
make sure that it's all flowing together
and at the end of the day what's my
reason for the book my reason for the
book is
make you better my reason for the book
is to make people understand yeah we all
agree we all should think that we're
great there's no reason for you to not
think that you're great if you don't
think you're great
ask yourself why why don't you think the
highest of yourself when you do people
have no no choice but to follow suit mmm
you had no choice but to follow suit a
lot of people they base it on their past
they base it on the life that they've
experienced up until this moment makes
you better yeah it does make you back
you better make you smarter yeah unless
you say it yeah man that's what's
interesting about it that's what's
interesting about life you can hear a
guy like you say that and then it
changes your perspective and then you'll
go out and take action that you might
not have taken before I had a 585 on my
SAT confessions I didn't take money
confession they give you 404 put your
name on a paper it's true story Wow I
guessed a BAC a da I did abracadabra
true story swear to God hand on my
mother's grave a BAC a da I didn't care
because there was a class trip that same
day I wanted to go great adventure I was
told they're not taking my SAT seriously
but prohibit me from furthering myself
in life that's what I was told at the
moment I said damn maybe I should have
maybe I should've applied myself maybe I
should have been different when I saw my
friends get their test scores back and
they were ecstatic 800-900 960s
everybody's going to college I felt like
the biggest idiot in the [ __ ] world
the biggest idiot in the [ __ ] world
because the same people that I want to
rush to go to great adventure with they
had taken an SAT a week before they
already got their work done mmm they did
everything they were supposed to do so
that moment of fun was real fun for them
I was the only dumbass that didn't
prioritize and take care of my [ __ ] so
I'm the only one going to Community
College
everybody's else off to Villanova Temple
University Drexel University god damn I
just got left behind why didn't y'all
tell me that y'all did it the week
before how come you only tell me that we
was serious about the college [ __ ] you
ain't tell me I was trying to go to
simple or Drexel all wait it's because
my life isn't their life they're focused
on themselves wow that they're doing
what they're supposed to do hey jackass
go sit by yourself and figure it out cuz
that's where you should be lesson learn
any opportunity given should be taking
series from this point on because if not
you can find yourself feeling just like
this it's not I get down on myself a
[ __ ] moment I learn from it I learned
from it now I got to take a goddamn test
you best believe I'm studying for that
[ __ ] test cuz I don't want to feeling
like I'm the guy mmm that didn't prepare
now I got a story to tell my kids about
what it feels like to be the kid in
class that didn't prepare that's got the
words great when they give all those
grades back but it's because of my
experience I don't look down on those
moments you take those moments you make
the best of them because their life
lessons it's that simple
you're saying it's positive but it's
really just simplicity that's real real
it's real and it's your life experience
and it's your life's lessons 100% but
the fact that a guy like you comes out
and talks about it like that that's
where it makes it really powerful
because it's not just something that you
learn from but now other people can
learn from your past too that's what I'm
hoping they'll look at themselves and
they realize like we all start from a
different spot you're not saying yeah
this is why I'm so candid I'm so candid
I'm so open they're there there is no
like guys I'm fine with being an open
book I'm fine with the good the bad ugly
I'm fine being flawed I'm fine with all
the things that have happened to me that
have been exposed I'm fine with it all I
don't hide from it I don't run from it I
don't I don't avoid any of it I'm fine
it's all right it's a bed that I made
for myself I happily lay in it and I'll
be fine figuring it out
moving forward son don't stop for nobody
man son don't [ __ ] stop so I'm gonna
be up in the morning regardless
that son is gonna be up in the morning
regardless of how I [ __ ] feel and how
depressed I am the Sun is gonna [ __ ]
shine in the morning and the night time
the moon gonna be there and you gonna
look up these days gonna keep going by
so do you let the days go by and look up
and you don't wasted a year doing what
what do you just pick it up alright I'll
figure it out made some mistakes
life goes on let me figure out life from
this point I'm a life goes on type of
guy you're a bad [ __ ] Kevin Hart
very very very inspirational and I'm
really glad you came down here and
talked about I'm I'm more than glad I
think that it took too long actually and
this is the first of what will be many
men I'm for sure I'm a fan too and I
just think what you're doing is not just
inspirational in terms of like what
you've been able to achieve and who you
are but also inspirational and how
you're so dedicated to helping other
people that means a lot to me it's very
it's very motivating it's very powerful
I wanna I want all your listeners know
that it's not it's not at all no this is
this is no way it could be you if you
were doing that just for talk and be
like listen just fake it and then become
that guy because you're honest if you
could do that and just say it and talk
[ __ ] forget about whatever it's fake
or not don't you guys trust me you will
be seeing more the financial fitness is
real this relationship with Chase and no
she's making sure you put me in a
position to give the information that I
have and to the people that really need
it that's the priority I will be sending
more kids to college this year shouts
out to 20 Robbins who's matching my
donation so you know I think I'm going
to end up probably probably having about
a good million 21.5 where we take it we
just dedicate that money and we just
provide free education
UNCF helps me as well that's a priority
like I said this health and wellness
side you'll see more from me vital so
calm you know get a part of this hustle
go get yours irresponsible on Netflix
filming filming we about to come out
Christmas there's so much so much [ __ ]
going on man listen if there's ever
anything you want promoted you want
people to know about it I'm your man
I like this say thank you brother I
really appreciate you appreciate you bye
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]